okay wait okay you would go there were  lots of music as it were wait wait wait  oh you're gonna be told and after the  kids have done a lip-sync for their life  and one girl lip syncs better than the  other to save herself and the other girl  has to sashay away and that's when I  tell one of the the loser  I'm not loser the one who did not win  but tell that girl to sashay away  I so happen should I serve a little bit  of sauces like well no there's a lot of  tension at this point because they're  waiting you you will have just lip-synch  for your life  okay and you're waiting for the verdict  okay right so you sort of praying inside  okay that you get to stay okay okay this  is the lip yeah yeah yeah nice yeah  that's quite a meaty tuck bye  [Applause]  Jackie my dear I'm sorry but this is not  your time now sashay away  [Applause]  [Music]  well done Jackie balls  [Applause]  [Music]